everybody what is going on welcome to
the 15th tkinter quote-unquote mega
series tutorial with Python 3 we're
going to be doing is adding a few more
options to our to intern window along
with the required back-end functions for
it so what we're going to go ahead and
do is scroll on down to our c BD c class
here write the app class coming down
here and as usual this is where we will
be writing our code so we're bar graph
we're going to have basically three
forms of indicators you're going to have
a top indicator a middle indicator so a
top indicator will go above the graph a
middle indicator will go basically on
the graph so things like moving averages
a top indicator might be relative
strength index and then a bottom
indicator so that'll be an indicator
that you put below the graph so again
this could be a relative strength index
or MACD or whatever so with that let's
go ahead and basically create these
indicators so first we'll do top indie
like that for top indicator we're going
to say that equals TK menu again menu
bar and we're going to say tear-off
equals 1 then we're going to go ahead
and we're going to say top indie indie
dot add underscore command and label
this one will be the first label
possible will be none so this will be
like we don't want any indicator at all
and then we'll say command equals the
lambda add top indicator whoops and the
parameter that we'll pass is simply none
because they chose none now we'll go
ahead and highlight this right here and
for now we'll have we're basically gonna
have three options for pretty much all
of these so this we want or well that
was two and then three so now the user
might decide they want RSI for a top
indicator or they might decide they want
to MACD for the top indicator so then
instead of none here will be just lower
case RSI and this one will be a lower
case map
d now we need to add this indicator
optionality to our menu so we'll just
say minibar ad underscore cascade and
then it will be label equals top
indicator and then the menu will be top
in D now I'm going to have each of these
have their own section so top middle
lower just because we have the space for
it when we're just going to go ahead and
use it but you might also combine all of
these we'll have three kind of
categories of indicators you could in
theory put them all under one tab called
indicator and then have a you know and
then under indicator you could have top
middle bottom and then you have over
that and it has another arrow over um
trying to see if any of these have an
option like that I don't see yeah so so
here you go file recent files and then
here are all bunch of recent files right
so it'd be like that like you know you
could go indicators and then let's say
top indicator and then this would be one
of your top indicators okay something
like that you could do that as well but
for now we'll just leave it the way it
is um so now we've got top indicator now
we basically want to do middle indicator
and a bottom indicator and so to do that
I'm just going to just copy this this
whole thing from the definition of the
top indicator as a menu item all the way
down to adding it as a cascade copy that
enter enter paste enter enter paste
let's add some space here and now let's
this one will be we'll call this main
indicator so this is the indicator
that's going on the main graph so main
eye and then copy paste paste paste and
then right here we paste as well the
main indicator we're not going to pass
RSI or MACD because those are on like a
different scale than the main graph
would be so that would look very weird
instead the main types of indicators
that you're going to see there are going
to be SMA for simple moving average or
EMA for exponential moving average so
this would be SMA EMA and instead of
having it be top indicator we're going
to call this main middle
um indicator and then menu may and I
we've already done that cool so now
we're going to do bottom indicator so
instead of top nd it's um bottom eye and
we'll copy that paste paste paste and
paste and actually oh we need to change
hat nice um this is a top indicator this
is so we're back into our main indicator
kind of group here
um so instead of add top indicator for
the lambda functionality there it needs
to be a middle so replace top with
middle copy paste paste and then here
this will be bottom to add bottom
indicator copy paste paste okay um so
now instead of top indicator this is
bottom indicator good and RSI MACD we
will allow both of those to be there so
that's good as well okay so now we've
got the menu items now we need the three
functions right add top add middle add
bottom now in theory we could do
basically and we can make a function
called add indicator and then passed two
parameters one is you know whether it's
top middle bottom or and then also what
the indicator is we might end up
condensing that later on down the road
from now let's just we'll make them
separate um especially cook yeah they
will for sure be able to be condensed
and it'll be necessary later on but
we'll do condensing the code and really
optimizing the code later on down the
road so now that we have this we need to
make basically all these functions okay
so we're going to go all the way to the
top of our scripts and basically where
we have all these constants here or at
least these default values and we need
to go ahead and have top indicator and
that's going to equal for now none and
then let's go ahead and copy that paste
paste
and then this will be a bottom in the
cater and then this one we're going to
call middle indicator so they all equal
none as a default in general that is how
people do it they just don't have any
default value and then we're finally
gonna have AMAs equal an empty list and
then SMAS equal an empty list and this
is because a lot of people like to do
crossovers here and they might have a
lot of VMAs or estimations that they
want to add so we're pretty much going
to let them do an infinite amount and
then what allow them when they hit none
that will just clear everything and then
they can kind of start over from there
there's also a few other things that we
could do there we could you know maybe
if as they add indicators maybe add like
a little button at the bottom for them
to X out of that indicator or something
like that we definitely look into that
in the future but again right now we're
just trying to you know kind of put
everything together get there and then
we can work on optimizing and then
especially user user interaction
basically with the with the program so
now we're going to go ahead and make our
functions that we need to make here so
we're going to go ahead and do get
define add top indicator and here you'll
see why we basically these these will be
pretty much all the same so for the
middle indicator is going to be slightly
different so we'll add add top indicator
and in fact I think what I'll do I think
what we'll do is we'll hold this off
until the next video because define it
doing all three of these was probably to
take a little bit so I'm going to cut
off the video here and so anyways if you
guys have any questions or comments feel
free you post them below no complaining
about cutting off voting and I'll do my
best to help you guys out or answer your
suggestions and all that otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support of subscriptions and
stay tuned to the next video